your female characters are like cool as
[ __ ] like I'd actually kick it with her
yeah most of the time you see a woman
and in a funny show and they're just
like like they're just they're not
people well it's because they're created
by desires of other people right a lot
of female characters are created by like
here's what I want in a woman like when
we were doing lucky Louie I had a lot of
fights with some of the writers about
Pamela because I wanted she's supposed
to be a nurse an overworked nurse mother
with a husband that doesn't really earn
any money and they wanted her to be a
sweet yeah sitcom wife so there was
always this kind of like you know it was
just so hard and it taught me why
um like we did an episode about her
having an orgasm
and she realizes that she hasn't had one
before and that she's 34 and then her
old she was then
and then she's having her first one and
she's like what kind of what what am I
how could this have been there all this
time and I never had one and then it
through the whole the rest of the
episode I'm trying to make her have
another one
it was one of my favorite episodes Dan
Mintz wrote it
um
with another guide and Aaron Shore or
something like that anyway it doesn't
well matters but uh but they
so I'm trying to make her and and uh my
neighbor his wife keeps screaming and
and and uh in sexually coming and I can
hear it through the wall so one day I
knock on the door and I ask him
um how do you make your wife come that
hard and he goes and he's kind of
standoffish what are you saying last
night I could hear her coming he's like
I was out of town last night
anyway that's great but Pamela so so the
thing that happened was that in the end
I kept trying to make her come again
after that first time and I can't do it
and finally she goes can we just go back
to where you come and I watch my shows
because I hate this
and that was her because we had another
solution to it but she I asked Pamela
what do you what would you do in that
situation she said I wouldn't want the
coming after I don't want it let me
watch my shows this is sex is the it's a
chore just do it you come
it's gross and I so I put that in and
the and one of the writers objected
saying I want her to claim her power I
want her to have her orgasm in his hers
[ __ ] her choice yeah well folks don't
get to live that way and it's also not
fun to watch and it's not it's not where
people meet and love each other is in
their strength it's in there it's in
their weakness right so I think that
that's what I always loved about her as
a character and as a writer and all
these things is that she shows her
weakest self she shows her you know how
hard it can be